klar also klar der fall aller zeiten
service und herzlich kommen zur
irgendwie leute heute steht der
ultimativen aber heute stelle ich mich
der ultimativen challenge und zwar werde
ich heute testen ob light produkte
wirklich so gut schmecken wie das
eigentlich auch kinder darf somit viele
verschiedene produkte ein
staatsoberhaupt leute die kohle ab sich
noch im rahmen der gesehen wir haben
schokolade werden chips werden milch und
obst im aus und ich werde testen ob man
einen unterschied schmeckt oder weil ich
das leitprodukt genauso gut ist wie das
eigentliche dann will ich den
unterschiedlich allein der verpackung
erkennen kann wenn ich mir jetzt die
augen verbinden max hinter der kamera
dann wenn man die sachen erreichen und
wir schauen ob ich es schaffe zu
erkennen welches produkt welches ist der
erste vergleich chips und zwar in light
und originalversion und der hier das
recht haben was richtig ist und ich
wusste nicht mal dass es überhaupt gibt
die zahlen stehen bereit beide sind
gefüllt sein können aber einmal ein
erster versuch tschüss crispy mega
lecker ich habe heute ein erstes schiff
ist sogar kein vergessen aber fühlen
sich jetzt nicht über fertig also wenn
die anderen deutlich kräftiger sind
können dass die lightship sein okay dann
mal die andere probieren sollen den
finger weißt du was ich so ein bisschen
fett leute ich habe euch kennt beides
schaffe man hätte mir auch das ist alles
nur einbildung sein also dieses cola
cola drei dinge dass man es gar nicht
ausstellen
hast du dich entschieden ja ich finde
ich habe gegen hier so einen stärkeren
nach geschmack im mund irgendwie so
einen stärkeren ich vermute mal dass der
geschmack von fett ist keine ahnung des
würde ich sagen das sind die leid
schiffs das sind die original
hier warten die augenbinde jetzt ich
gedacht na ja aber keine scheiße dass
meine erste mal ne und hätte schwören
können dass die deutlich mehr sind nach
geschmack haben was ich besonders viel
geschmack leiten haben vielleicht ist es
glück wie so vieles ist möglich aber man
schmeckt er würde wirklich nicht okay
leute ich will sagen waren direkt weiter
und zwar als nächstes mit schokolade und
lightshow klar so sieht das aus hier
sind unterschiedliche marken arbeiten
sowieso nicht das kann ich nicht sagen
das muss man auch schmecken
ich habe auch eine ganz klassische
schokoladig vergleichen wie viel zucker
drin haben einmal 1200 grad und einmal
das muss ich mir gerade sind die teller
genannt ich mal sagen habe wird mir gut
gerne herzattacke junge ich wünschte es
wäre eindeutig jetzt es ist nicht alles
mal probieren
da kann ich doch noch mal 200 gramm
schokolade zu probieren bitte ganz
kurzes haar
süßmilch es ist so schwer es 50 kräfte
für mich wieder also die schokolade hat
auf jeden fall mehr süße beim essen
gehabt da kam die süße später deswegen
sag ich das jetzt delight schokolade
das hier ist die normale nicht leid
schokolade richtig gerade ich war so
kurz dann so kurz davor es anderswo zu
sagen
mal guckt es dir etwas ist eigentlich
seien auf 100 gramm davon 2 49 stunden
und hier ca ca glücklich klaus keine
scheiße erwarte ist auch wirklich klaus
bitte selbst mal aus wo die leute hier
sind die königsdisziplin wir treten an
in der disziplin cola light gegen cola
das ist der absolute klassiker von den
geschmackstests wurden wie gesagt ich
muss wissen
ich muss das wissen ich denke ich so
nicola das ist ja immerhin ein geschenk
gut ausprobieren
jetzt geht es auch weiter jetzt geht so
die juristen streiten das ja wohl noch
länger
klar also klar der fall aller zeit
hoffnung richtet sich jetzt um ihre cola
light echte cola dem ich muss schnell
machen das kombiniert mit dass er sich
beim lösen
man merkt dass man merkt es daran dass
cola light viel viel mehr schon und man
merkt es daran dass die süßer ist von
irgendwie hat er richtig nach geschmack
oder leiter zum leichten nachgeschmack
ich doch nicht nur süßungsmittel hatte
er wollte halt nicht so ne sache die man
sofort denkt bei sowas gebracht weil das
original liga ist dabei entfaltet haben
mit bibel etabliert sondern das sage ich
dass uhr leitprodukt okay ich bin
gespannt ob wir sind richtig schmeckt
anders als bei schokolade ist ja nur ein
kleiner prozentsatz wert hier nicht okay
nicht so voll irgendwie so ein
nachgeschmack habe ich gefühl vielleicht
so als wenn ein bisschen weniger festen
kann sein okay das nächste glas
okay okay da fühlt sich an als wäre es
ganz ganz eindeutig ich sage links warme
milch rechts normale milch
ich will man schmeckt deutlich da aber
sowieso einen leichten nicht schon
vorher gehabt und hier halt einfach mehr
dabei denn auch das video leute ich habe
35 4 test hier bekommt endlich ehrlich
gesagt nicht gedacht dass es so gut
schreiben an die kommentare an leute auf
ihr selbst schon mal für euch getestet
habe zum beispiel cola cola light oder
fettarme milch gegen normale mediziner
wir dabei selbst ein unterschied gespürt
hat weil ich glaube bei vielen produkten
ist es mehr ein bildung als wirklichkeit
das was von diesem video direkt auf
jeden fall hier nur folge was das geht
ab da gibt es noch mehr sachen von mir
also wenn ich mal nicht gerade könnt ihr
gerne in folge was ist jeder check hier
ist eine verlinkt schaut sich gerne an
und tschüss